It is not profitable.
And in the face of unprofitability
of the farmer and the farmer,
many farmers and many ranchers
begin to wonder if it is worth it or not
to harvest their land.
And what has page done?
One can think,
well, then page
who has made a package of measures to help them,
right?
What has page done?
Page has passed a law.
I know that this eh,
some
digital journalist viewer will say
is not possible,
but I will try to be clear.
Page has passed a family farming law
by which if a land
ceases to be profitable
and the farmer
decides to stop growing it,
the government to cross the stain,
through the Department of Agriculture,
can be expropriated.
That's Bolivarian,
but this is approved
in the Parliament of Andalusia la mancha
with the only votes of the PSOE
and was the last one they approved in the
last law of the legislature.
We are now insisting that
remove that sword from the farmers' loop
and we have asked,
by means of a bill in the popular party
to reject this law,
to modify it,
to eliminate the expropriator component.
But what is this Emiliano Garcia page,
who at a time like this,
where agriculture is not profitable
and there are farmers who can afford to think
I will stop harvesting my land
because it is not profitable.
Instead of guaranteeing them water
instead of launching a Contingency Fund
economic
to compensate for losses with direct aid.
What page has done is
have a law
for which he can expropriate the land.
And the second idea
that has given a page to farmers has been,
Hey,
if you guys have problems,
get angry.
The solution given by paje to the farmer
and the farmer
is to get into debt.
He has told him that whoever has problems
to go to the bank and ask and ask for money at the bank.
This is pageboy.
He told you, hey,
you're in financial trouble,
livestock farmer,
go to the bank and ask for a loan.
That the farmer
that the dairy farmer stains it
no need to go into debt,
needs water.
Water for irrigation
water to feed their animals.
Need a pack that is not even an environmentalist
nor socialist
in order to compensate
the day-to-day farming and livestock farming.
And it needs a contingency fund
that at a time like the one we live in,
with exorbitant prices,
have the necessary financial aid
to make their agricultural and livestock holding viable.
That's what the farmer needs.
No land expropriation law needed
by which they can take away his land,
nor does he need to go to the bench to hesitate.
Need real help
for a field that has to be for the future